we have looked at trig functions for
some time now we've developed past the
idea of thinking about them just in
triangles just as ratios where we're now
developing thing about them as functions
okay we don't leave the triangle
understanding as you've noticed many
times even when we're looking at graphs
right and we were trying to establish
this or I think it was swats in yourself
it doesn't matter it's same quick ways
this is very easy to prove with a
triangle you just draw the train right
so we don't leave triangles behind but
where we're moving past them is noticing
the tree relates to how much other
things so much so imagine that the trig
functions themselves you can work with
them even when you don't in what the
angles are okay so we're going to
explore this little bit of more here's
an example of a question if you know
what the value of one trig function
value is right sine theta equals seven
or twenty five an actual number on the
basis of that evaluate cosine okay now
just before we launch into answering
this question why would he ever ask this
like what's the point
good morning behind the question like
this apart from just mathematical
curiosity while telling you very quickly
okay over the side here do you remember
when we expanded the idea of on the trig
functions being in a triangle we went to
the unit circle do you remember that
okay we said all right imagine the
Cartesian plane around this and you have
beauty you you've got a right angle
coming up off of the x axis let's here
now on the unit circle the hypotenuse is
equal to on the unit circle I have what
is equal to one
thank you we're awake okay and then on
the basis of that you can very quickly
determine that these two sides here are
going to be costing up and sine theta
right and that's where we got the fact
that the coordinates of any given point
on the circumference of the unit
something like that point cos theta sine
theta and you can see here that if I
have something going off at an angle cos
and sine frequently refer to the
horizontal and vertical components of
whatever you're looking at okay example
if what you've got here right thinking
forward - projectile motion is a point
of origin and an object being fired off
at an angle at a certain velocity okay
you're like I'm going to aim upwards at
45 degrees and I'm going to throw it at
30 meters a second so like that okay
because I've got a really good arm right
yeah actually said that what we would do
here to understand situation it's what
we will do when we go to projectile
motion is we will split up this movement
and an angle into its horizontal and
vertical component and their cause
inside right so sometimes you know what
and you want to find out the other I'll
give you one other quick example again
going on this same thing but if instead
you've got a a mass right some some
object over here and it's attached to a
string and I Illustrated it like this
before right and if you are rotating it
around a central point because it the
object is moving in a circle we call
this unsurprisingly circular motion okay
now how is this object moving around we
alluded to this before the point is that
it's moving at an angle like that
perpendicular to the radius which we've
proved okay but being at the movement
and an angle it's going to have a
horizontal and of them
component right so in order to work with
this thing we have to separate out these
parts one of them will be cosine one
will be signed so this is why I like
this this question is very much in a
vacuum like what is this all about
okay well its leading there okay so
think about these two things as part of
mission that's where we're gonna head
eventually so how do I solve it the
first thing I'm going to do is I'm going
to say well how did I just do this like
how I visualize this thing side V equals
7.25 I said even though we've moved
beyond triangles we don't move away from
triangles we keep them as our
understanding of treatment so let's draw
a triangle or a triangle - like this
right angle triangle excuse me if I put
theta in the corner and I learn that
site leader is 7 on 25 sine is which
ratio which two sides opposite on
hoppity's opposite on hypotenuse okay so
I've got 7 over 25 right now just keep
in mind those two numbers could be 14 +
54 21 + 75 or any other combination
because all these triangles can be
similar but this will be the simplest
one it's the simplest right here okay
now I know it's a right-angled triangle
right so we're going to get to this
third time in a second but suppose we
didn't right how would we approach how
do we answer this question right well I
can work out if I want usually if I want
coz-theta I need to know what theatre is
right so directly from here I can make
this statement I can say sine theta
equals now you've seen this function
before and you've met it in your 9 when
you first left reading you're like oh
look we can find angles if we know sides
up okay so this is sine inverse is a
minus 1 up there but doesn't mean 1 over
sine because that's Cosette okay so this
is sine inverse cos it's a thing you can
go if you can actually would you like
you to get your back
now and you can punch this in okay now
dory anticipate because this thing in
here it's not a half it's not really
three on two it's not one or three it's
not a nice exact value the way that we
are familiar with right when you punch
inside invest seven or twenty five and
press Enter which I'd like you to do now
you should expect some sort of random
decimal garbage out of there right so
7/25 okay so what do we have
just give me to the nearest degree
that's all I want yeah 680 thank you
just 16 I just want a bullpup okay now
don't clear that don't clear it now that
I know what fear is
and even though I haven't written down
what it is exactly this has got it right
I can now say therefore close theta is
equal to it and I just say cos and ants
all right cause it's and I get a number
right and I get an exact number now you
can probably see that's kind of that's
kind of suspicious right weird decimal
guys but you end up with something nice
and again it's not bad surprising based
on this triangle that we've got here
what might be a better less awkward
less time-consuming approach to working
out cosine edgy
okay fantastic all I need
cuz I've got a right angle triangle here
is use Pythagoras down here okay we know
what this is going to be equal to right
but just in case it's not a nice at the
green plaid the way that I would get
this is the square root of hypotenuse
squared minus the other sites with which
sure enough will give you 24 7 24 25 one
of the uncommon part the green cards
after five 12 30 so a better approach to
this would be write a little mystery and
introducing a sine inverse in this
decimal like I do is just to go straight
here right
identify what this third side is by
Pythagoras
and then you can just read off therefore
closely Dutch equals 24 on 25 it's all
you need to do you don't need to appeal
to a calculator to do this did that make
sense
do you agree with that okay except
there's a problem there's a problem we a
little problem I might be right but I
might not be okay
because that was a very scared amount of
information provided to you in this
question right and the first step that I
made I didn't highlight it to you so you
wouldn't want it but I wonder if anyone
has the first step that I made added
information to this question that wasn't
there what was the first step that I
made
yeah they can make it very good so I put
the triangle here that was a way of
understanding it right as soon as I mean
a triangle my value for theta is acute I
should say as soon as I'm in a right
angle triangle my feeders are cute
okay now you might think what's the big
deal okay you can go ahead you can try
this right and you'll still end up like
this is a legitimate answer but what if
theta were not acute okay
just quickly underneath where you've
drawn this okay draw for me a on a small
set of axes but make it horizontally
very long okay just for the sake of
illustration I'm going to draw sine
theta on here and I'm going to draw more
than I usually do we usually go from
naught to 360 let go a little further so
I've gone from what
1,260 I don't know some awkward number
okay so I've gone further don't want to
do and the reason why is to hide the
fact that if sine theta equals seven on
25 there is not just one solution the
calculator is only told us one solution
but there's a whole bunch of them
watch how do I show you this well the
range of sine minus 1 to 1 range is a
y-value domain is all revised of X so if
that's where one is where 7 on 25 like
roughly give me a ballpark it's Mike I
guess a third the way up it's less than
half isn't it okay so I'm just gonna
roughly put that in I'm gonna draw in it
it's something like this it said okay
that's y equals seven or twenty five sir
sine theta equals seven 21 25 means
where do these two things intersect
answer a lot of places in fact there's
an infinite set of solutions it's a sine
theta equals 10 plus 25 right now
ordinarily I wouldn't be that big a deal
right but it causes us problems if we
have a look at these and what cosine is
equal to for those are the values okay
example we said before as soon as we
drew the triangle we were locked in to
this solution the acute solution the
first solution the calculator could find
well the only one that it's in program
to fire but immediately you can see
there's another solution right there
right now let's just think in terms of
domain right this is 0 90 180 270 360
okay start to familiarize yourself with
the features of this and where they
exist so here 0 90 right in there
there's our cute solution so where is
this second solution in terms of domain
in terms of domain it's between
okay so I can talk in terms of quadrants
or what I'm trying to get out is one of
you one of the values that go along with
that so same quadrant I'm not quite the
same as saint-germain you'd say theta is
between 900 degrees well you could say
alternatively second quadrant okay so
I'm looking at obtuse angle okay but
what does cosine do when theatre' is
obtuse what does course I do
you can either mentally draw it or you
can think back to this guy what to do
it's negative isn't it thank you so to
verify this let's just do this actual
number go back to where you did sine
inverse December 25 punch that back into
your calculator okay now you'll get that
familiar sixteen point two six whatever
that's coming forward from the origin to
get the obtuse equivalence right the
obtuse equivalent of that angle I've got
to go 180 minus that angle right so I'm
not considering theta equals 180 degrees
minus sine inverse of that okay so again
just so I can write it conveniently what
am I going to get it's just gonna be a
hundred and sixty-four you can get the
actual decimal I would like us to do 180
minus the answer okay so you get your
163 point blah-blah-blah-blah-blah now
I'm gonna repeat what I did here just to
verify be really sure right I'm now
gonna go there for cos theta is equal to
and when you do because it's as we
predicted you get the same magnitude
right it's still 24 and 25 right but you
get a minus sign because in the second
quadrant
when theater is obtuse okay cosine takes
on a different sign so we need two
pieces of information here right in
order to work out one shape function
from another one firstly you just need a
number right and then you can do
Pythagoras but secondly you actually
need a bit of a restriction I kind of
left this off right you need
no for example in here and theta is
acute or Theater is obtuse or theater is
whatever they might give you a domain
restriction to actually say it okay but
if they don't provide you that you can't
conclusively know which one you are
I knew this word or are you that that
make sense